[Musique]
cette semaine au ciné c'est du 20 au 26
mars plein de belles choses à voir
d'excellents films de très bons films
je vais commencer par les excellents que
je vais citer rapidement qui est con à
la fiche depuis un certain temps mais
qu'il faut absolument voir grâce à dieu
de françois ozon évidemment la favorite
l'excellent film du réalisateur grèce et
giorgos lanthimos le mystère henry pic
et green book qui a eu comme vous savez
un oscar à hollywood et aussi cette
semaine de très bonnes comédies à la
fiche
la première c'est bon bébé le visage
vélo ça avec sandrine kiberlain qui
raconte un peu les affres pour une maman
du départ en fait de l'enfant de l'aîné
de la maison c'est pas toujours facile
donc le film en parle avec finesse et
tendresse et le second sur tous ces
rebelles qui est infime
la lame ou de vie avec un trio assez
soucieux cécile de france
audrey lamy et l'excellente yolande
moreau les deux autres étant excellent
possible alors c'est quoi cette histoire
c'est l'histoire de trois ouvrières cry
dans une usine de fabrication de boîtes
de conserves de poissons qui vont se
rebeller un petit peu contre leur chef
contre ce qu'elles subissent au
quotidien
alors c'est assez trash mais il faut le
voir c'est du tarantino à la française
on va bien pour qu attendez vous à
quelque chose qui les ménages qui revue
et donc c'est à voir dans nos salles
cette semaine
aussi des sexes
hormis disparaît que le pognon des
belges mais pourquoi tu le rap
indiqueront quoi tu veux te fasses des
britanniques m'habite
[Musique]